[Applause]
you pay for you you people have been
smoking cafe thing you know you know
what cafe thing is right go play fake
show the tweet Donald Trump tweeted this
week despite the constant negative press
copy fake disease silent that's the
secret to the word ko PHA favored
Elizabeth pronouncing it this week it's
like the ancient more it okay Coface
they leave the beer co faith a this is
the part of the assisted living facility
commercial with the grown up children
say that's when we knew dad could no
longer live on this off
living in the era of school faith and
you know people suffering people say
this is no big deal what you know what
the last thing I want to hear from this
White House is his fingers just pressed
the wrong button not not to worry this
morning President Trump put Jared Jared
Kushner officially in charge of copay
pay so that's taken care of it now to
the big news America's long nightmare as
the world leaders is coming to an end
the clown who runs our country the
laughingstock on the world stage that is
Donald Trump pulled out of the Paris
climate record this week as you know I
know
how brave of you a meek who anyway I
still have faith in liberals anyway yeah
isn't that said I feel like I'm binge
watching the fall of the Roman Empire
set to the music from Benny Hill you
know I I usually wake up to the sounds
of birds chirping I open my window today
a sparrow went [ __ ] you I mean it is
hard to exaggerate how alone America is
on this issue 190 countries in the world
signed on to the Paris Accord that's
pretty much all of them North Korea sign
really the country that is always
threatening to blow up the planet wants
to save the planet not just every
country corporations greedy [ __ ]
corporations are for this ExxonMobil is
for this the CEO of General Electric
said he was very disappointed which hurt
Trump because he thinks he's a general
I mean everybody gets this flick Donald
Trump and the Republican Party Google is
for the Paris Accords Apple the Vatican
Google Apple and Nevada cand that's the
access of virgins everyone is on this
pace what Trump says no no we said he
listened to his advisors you know he's
got great people around them they said
they gathered all the data and they all
came to the same delusion that we have
to focus on bigger threats like Kathy
Griffin's photo shoots the things that
really matter and yes Donald Trump says
he's going to renegotiate the deal
because nobody negotiates better than
Donald Trump really says the guy you
cannot even get his own wife to hold his
and
[Applause]
like you know you know why it was all in
the paper do you know why he did this
probably okay so yes that he makes a big
speech in the Rose Garden soon to be the
cactus garden and he says we don't want
other leaders of other countries
laughing at us anymore and there won't
be they won't feel okay they weren't
laughing at us you waddling out house
they were laughing at you
[Applause]
thing is no here's what happened he just
got back from his big overseas trip and
the European leaders screwed up
they didn't kiss his ass like the Saudis
did they didn't put his face on
buildings and let them stroke their orb
and the Pope made a fat joke about him
and the French guy said he won the
handshaking Khan says you guys are mean
to me now you get gold get coal
what is it the Santa Claus doctrine
Donald Trump is not going to let those
euro weenie countries like France and
Norway tell him he can't use hairspray
he needs a lot of energy is it any
wonder that's 43 percent of registered
voters in the last poll say they want
him impeached and until he's impeached
they say they'd like some of whatever
Tiger Woods is on